hi my name is Sundra brother Gopal look
with Starwood Capital Group manage their
business in India South expansionist
Thank You longer for your question on
what are the greatest security and
safety to the east asia and naturally
tabular and I do think actually in an
interesting way the greatest the
greatest security issue station is is
the is potentially the the problem with
the west and the fact that the West it's
an attention to what they're doing to
their own economic situation in case is
causing most people responding the most
common the stage I don't think world to
see a couple it's clear that the world
isn't a couple and so much of how much
about replacing gear is giving you to do
a little issue is regular lesson and
their own respect unimportant and
extrapolation answer